Hello, everyone.
This is the question
review for the drugs
for multiple sclerosis.
So we have a 52-year
-old female with a
10-year history of MS
and hyperlipidemia,
developing a sudden
worsening of weakness
and a partial loss of
vision, which has occurred
for over two days.
she was started on
medication but was told
that this drug could
increase her triglyceride
level if taking
long term which of the
following does this
describe so it seems
to me that this patient
has had this disorder
for many years and
what's standing out
is that she's getting
this partial loss of
vision so to me it would
point that she's having
a episode of optic
neuritis so we know
that with optic
neuritis there's a loss
of myelin in the in the
nerves of the eye and
the other thing we
know she's treated but
if this drug was used
long term it can
affect her lipid panel
so first of all I
have to say to myself
what do we use for
the situation of an
exacerbation especially
optic neuritis so we know
that the glucocorticoids
are used okay
and that would make
sense the other thing as
I mentioned in the
lecture glucocorticoids
are effective for many
conditions, especially
when we're dealing
with inflammation.
But we want to limit
use because they
cause many adverse
effects. And one of them
is they will increase
gluconeogenesis.
They will increase
fatty acids.
And remember,
with fatty acids,
that can lead
to an increase
of LDL and
triglycerides. If she was
taking this for
shorter than two weeks,
this should not
happen. But the idea
is if she was
taking it long term.
So I'm going to
vote that this
is a glucocorticoid or
corticosteroid. So
alimtuzumab, no.
Alimtuzumab is
going to be the
CD52 drug that will
help to destroy
pathogenic T
cells and B cells.
Fingolamide is the
modulator that acts at
the sphingosine 1
-phosphate 1 receptor
and it's going to
allow for sequestering
of lymphocytes and that
would be a benefit.
But if anything,
fingolimod, aside from
all of these causing
some level of
immunosuppression and
higher risk of infection,
this will cause
probably bradycardia.
Methylprenisolone is
the correct answer here,
and this would be
appropriate for the optic
neuritis. You would
start methylprenisolone
intravenously for a
few days, and then the
patient would be
tapered off to maybe an
oral prednisone for a
little bit longer and
then finally weaned off.
And we wean off because
we want to not have
that effect that's
suppressing the
hypothalamic pituitary axis.
Natilizumab is going
to bind to VCAM
and by doing that
you're not going to
have the shuttling in
of toxic lymphocytes
through the blood
-brain barrier.
And then lastly,
rituximab is the anti
-CD20, okay? And this
one is interesting
because, remember,
the target of
CD20 would be the
B cells for the
autoimmunity. But
it does have some
effect at lowering
the T cells as well.
So remember, glucocorticoids
stop everything
from the first step,
the starting point. it
will increase lipocortin
and by doing that
it inhibits phospholipase
A2 and then you
don't get production of
arachnidonic acid and
then on both sides of
the tree so to speak
you don't get production
of prostaglandins
or leukotrienes and
that helps the anti
-inflammatory response
and then remember NSAIDs
would block cyclooxygenase
1 and 2 and that's
going to decrease PGE2
which is involved in
pain, edema, inflammation
and then lastly
the target of aspirin
for cardiac prophylaxis
so to speak is going
to be thromboxane so
you're not going to get
platelet aggregation
and then remember
glucocorticoids just
like vitamin A, D,
E, and K and other
hormones such as
thyroid, estrogen,
progesterone are going
to get now an increase
of steroid and
receptor dimerization
in the response elements
and that's going
to increase
transcription machinery.
So you're not going
to get messenger RNA
being made to protein
and getting a response.
And then as I
mentioned, we talked
about the metabolism
problem, which
this patient in
this question might
experience if
taking long-term.
Increasing aldosterone
is going to allow
for retention of
sodium in water, and
that can raise blood
pressure and cause
edema. And then with
the bone, you're going
to increase
osteoclasts, and that's
going to break down
bone. And in addition,
glucocorticoids can
also have an effect
on vitamin D absorption
and excretion. And
if you don't have
enough vitamin D, your
levels of calcium
absorption will be
impaired. And that can
lead to osteoporosis,
especially if we're
giving these long-term.
And in fact, some
patients that use
Because glucocorticoids
throughout the course
of their disease, many
times during their
life, sometimes will
in fact show changes
in bone, bone loss,
and it's not uncommon
that these patients
will need a
bisphosphonate. And
bisphosphonates are one of
the main drug targets
for osteoporosis,
and you will go through
that in endocrine.
A 36-year-old male
presented with muscle
weakness and tingling,
double vision, and
increased episodes of
fatigue that has worsened.
After a full
physical exam, which
include an MRI,
a diagnosis
of multiple
sclerosis was made.
He was started on
medication which recruits
T lymphocytes into
lysosomes. Which of the
following does this
describe? So this to
me sounds like the
sequesterer. So the drug
binds, it takes with
it the T lymphocytes,
it holds it or
sequesters it in an area.
And then when you
get to the lysosome,
there's going
to be a break, a
destruction of these
pathogenic T cells. So
hopefully you
should realize that
that's going to be
fingolimod, okay? And
that is, in fact,
the correct answer.
Dimethylfumarate is
going to be the one that
is a pro-drug converted
to monomethylfumarate,
which is a
metabolite, and that's
going to increase the
transcription machinery
of antioxidant,
specifically glutathione.
Glatyromer will enhance
T helper cells too,
which are anti
-inflammatory. And then the
other thing is that they
increase BDNF, brain
-derived neurotropic
factor. And that actually
increases the lifespan
of the neurons.
Interferon beta 1a
is a cytokine this
acts at the Janus kinase
signal transduction
and activation of
transcription there's
going to be a
phosphorylation and that
too will have an
effect at stopping
activation of the T
cells and also the
migration through the
blood-brain barrier.
And then acralizumab,
okay, going back
to how that drug
would work, we would
say that that is
a CD20 drug, okay,
and that's going
to affect B cells.
okay so remember there
is presence of these
receptors in the heart
and there may be a
change in potassium
conduction and in that case
if you're getting
more potassium in
especially if we're
talking about the pacemaker
in the av node that
can affect the action
potential and the patient
can get bradycardia.
In addition to wanting
to evaluate the EKG
for this adverse effect,
we need to make sure
that we're testing the
patient for varicella
because if we are
concerned that they don't
have enough antibodies,
they can get an
activation of ******
zolster, which is known as
shingles, which can
be very painful in the
average person. But
somebody with MS probably
would be even in an
even worse situation.
And this is our dimethyl
fumarate. So you're
going to get activation
of transcription
here on the response
elements. okay and
remember with pml this
is a very rare adverse
effect it does tend
to happen in those who
are immunosuppressed
like an hiv patient and
with this you're
going to activate a
somewhat dormant virus
in the white matter of
the brain and when then
that does happen the
patient is going to
present with lack of
coordination they may
have some cognition
defects and some problems
with you know even
movement so this is
an important adverse
effect you need to
determine is it an adverse
effect or does it have
to do with maybe the
patient having a
worsening in MS as well.
And then this one, as
I mentioned, is going
to enhance the T
helper cells too. And
that's important.
That's neuroprotective
along with increasing
brain-derived neurotropic
factor. And remember,
if you're losing
the fat with respect
to a subcutaneous
administration,
the idea here is we
want to rotate the site,
okay? This is
common with any drug
that it's administered
subcutaneously.
And then remember,
the infusion reactions
can be managed by
preventing the release
of histamine from
IgE by giving an
antihistamine such
as diphenhydramine,
Okay, there's also
some cytokine release.
Some physicians,
as I mentioned, can
use glucocorticoids,
but again, that would
depend on the
situation and we would
not give a high dose
of glucocorticoid.
So a 38-year-old female
presented with muscle
weakness and tingling,
double vision,
and an increased episode
of fatigue that has
worsened in the past
years. She was diagnosed
with MS and was
started on medication,
which also acts as
a cytokine to treat
hepatitis C infection.
Which of the following
does this describe?
So again, what gives
you the clue is a
cytokine. And we know that
interferons are, in
fact, cytokines. The
other thing to know is
that with respect to
managing other
infections, we know that
interferon can be used
for hepatitis B or C.
one thing to know
about using this in
patients that have ms
the overall mechanism of
interferon is the
same it's a cytokine
it's going to increase
janus kinase you're
going to get
phosphorylation increase in
signal transduction
and activation of
transcription that happens
in the nucleus it's
the same but with
patients that we're trying
to manage ms that
effect is going to
decrease the activation
of those T lymphocytes
that are pathogenic
and also prevent
their entry through the
blood-brain barrier.
So C is the
correct answer.
What I want to say
about the others is
cladribine is an
antineoplastic. It's an
S-phase, which stands
for DNA synthesis.
It's going to
target pyrimidines.
And by targeting
pyrimidines, and
they're not being
made, that's going
to reduce RNA and
DNA synthesis.
So what that
would mean is
that, again, it
will prevent that
process in the
lymphocytes.
With respect to
teraflunamide, it's
similar. But this
one does so by acting
as an inhibitor of
a specific enzyme
known as dihydrooridate
dehydrogenase.
So these are
pretty much trying
to achieve the
same thing.
Cladribine is
sometimes used
for hairy cell leukemia.
teraflunamide,
its metabolite
known as
lefunamide, can be
used for patients
that have RA.
These two, specifically
since they're going
to affect pyrimidine,
anything that affects
pyrimidine and purines
and the formation
of nucleic acids for
DNA and RNA, we're going
to worry about patients
that are considering
pregnancy. So being
on adequate birth
control, especially with
this one, is going to
be especially important
To the point that
this lasts in the body
for a longer period
of time So they do
suggest if you're taking
oral contraception,
you do continue for two
years So the warnings
for pregnancy should
be strong, especially
with these two Okay.
And then L-M2
-cymab is CD52.
Okay.
And then
rituximab is CD20.
Okay. And you'll
see that later with
rituximab is going to
be one of the drugs
that we use for B
-cell lymphoma. Because
remember, in the
lecture, we talked
about the CD20.
Although it affects T
-cells, It's specific
for the B cells and
the autoimmune issue
with MS patients.
Okay, so when you
give interferon
through the first
few days, the patient
can feel terrible,
flu-like symptoms.
Depression,
okay, when we're
thinking about
patients that
are depressed,
probably the issue
is that interferon
can decrease
the synthesis of
neurotransmitters and
that specifically with
depression is going
to be serotonin.
Injection reactions,
okay? So injection
reactions occur with
many of these.
So you can do
pretreatment. And then
lastly, with the anemia,
we will be considering
the fact that
interferon may
affect erythrocytes.
So you may not
get erythropoiesis
and that will change now
and lower your
red blood cells.
So as I mentioned,
across the board,
a patient's CBC is
going to be critical
before they're put
on these medications
and during the
treatment, okay?
Monitoring for signs
of infection, making
sure that they're
getting the
appropriate vaccines
before they start these
medications, all
very important, okay?
And this is the Janus
kinase pathway. So
kinase is phosphorylate,
and now you're
going to get dimerization
action that happens
inside the nucleus
on response elements.
So a 28-year-old
female presented with
muscle weakness and
tingling, double vision,
and increased episodes
of fatigue, which
has worsened over the
past three months. She
was started on
teriflunamide, which of the
following is the
mechanism of this drug.
Does it block
the M3 receptors?
So the answer is no.
M3 receptor
blockade would be
something like
daraphenicin,
oxybutynin, atropine,
dicyclamine.
Those are other
drugs for other uses.
So with daraphenicin
and oxybutynin,
blocking this receptor
will be very, very
useful in those patients
that have incontinence.
so if she was having
episodes of wetting
herself a lot this would
be appropriate okay
but that is not the
case we're not dealing
with incontinence
right now inhibition of
dihydroorotate
dehydrogenase as i just
mentioned maybe a few
moments ago that's
going to be the mechanism
of teriflunamide.
And by doing this,
inhibiting this
enzyme, you're stopping
the synthesis of
pyrimidines. And that's
going to reduce T
and B cell proliferation
and reduce your
inflammatory response.
Inhibition of
phospholipase
A2, that's
going to be our
glucocorticoids,
like prednisone,
methylprednisolone,
fluticacone,
beta-methasone,
dexamethasone. You'll
understand them a little
bit more later on.
Targeting the
sphingosine 1-phosphate
receptor, that's going
to be fingolimod. That's
the sequestrer of
lymphocytes. and then
targeting CD20 is
going to be rituximab,
aqualizumab,
afatumamab, and then the
newer one that
is given twice a
year, okay? It has
a longer half-life.
What other advice
should she be given?
Well, since she's a 28
-year-old patient, we
would advise her to
not consider pregnancy
for two years after
taking this medication.
and the warning
would be she should
be on some oral
contraception. The other
thing is whenever we're
dealing with drugs
that may affect
pregnancy, that may be
teratogenic, you need
to do a pregnancy
test. Even if the patient
says to you, well,
you know, I don't
know, maybe, maybe not,
it's always good to
check to make sure,
okay? Because there
may be certain things
that we don't know
about. If patients
are taking, say,
inducers of cytokine
P450, and they're using
oral contraception,
that can, in fact,
rev up the metabolism
of those drugs, and
that can lead to
pregnancy. So it's
always safe to do the
baseline pregnancy
test to make sure,
and then counsel the
patient on how these
drugs can affect the
developing fetus.
Okay,
so we're going to affect
pyrimidine synthesis
and for MS,
we're going to
inhibit RNA and
DNA synthesis and
that will stop
the proliferation
of these cells.
a 62 year old male
with a 15 year history
of multiple sclerosis
and a recent diagnosis
of angina presented
to his physician with
worsening symptoms
and poor speech he is
not responding to
conventional treatment
and his disease has
progressed his physician
decided on a medication
which would require
him to go through a
full cardiac exam.
Which of the following
does this describe?
So from this case,
we can see that
this patient may,
after 15 years,
now be in a secondary
progressive form of MS,
where they're
getting symptoms and
none of the medications
that were slowing
the progression
now are working.
and that is you know
difficult because you
know by then the patient
may in fact be on
their way to being
disabled and that creates
a lot of issues remember
psychosocial effects
you know the patient
not being able to work
having some depression
understandably so
but we're told here he
has angina and he has
to have some pre
-testing cardiac wise EKG
echocardiogram. So looking
at the choices now,
botulinum toxin. So
botulinum toxin, if
you give this
medication, it's going to
relax muscle. And we
said for this lecture
that Botox could be
used for patients
that have and overactive
bladder because
the idea with these
drugs is to stop
acetylcholine because
acetylcholine is going
to be involved in
muscle contraction.
Okay, going back
to that mechanism.
The way it does
that is by stopping
the fusion of the
vesicle because when
you fuse the
vesicle, then, so to
speak, acetylcholine
gets spit out.
And it does so by
having an effect
on the SNAP25 snare
protein, okay?
But we're not talking
here about a symptom
of the disease.
We're talking about
the fact that the
patient has progressed,
okay? We know
nothing about
him being incontinent.
So right now, this would
not be the best answer.
Mitoxantrone is
probably the best answer
because remember,
in the lecture, we
said that this drug
is an antineoplastic.
It's an interculating
agent, so it's going
to bind to the DNA
ladder and cause breaks.
And by doing that,
it's going to inhibit B
and T cells. okay
that's important to note
the other thing is that
it will decrease the
function of b cells and
by doing that it stops
antibody production
okay so this would be
the best answer and
the other thing because
we know that this is a
relapsing a secondary
progressive symptom
is the cardiac problem
because I mentioned
that the drugs of the
interculating cancer
chemotherapeutic class
they do form free
radicals and that could
be a good thing if
we're trying to target
pathological cells
like cancer cells but
it does affect contractile
proteins and that
might affect contraction,
especially if
we're talking about
the ventricles. And the
idea here is that this
drug, perhaps, and
especially doxorubicin
that I told you
was red and ruby, can
do this to the heart.
And certain times
patients who are taking
doxorubicin, maybe
for breast cancer,
may develop something
called dilated
cardiomyopathy. And the
patient would present as
having symptoms of
congestive heart failure.
So doing a cardiac
exam on baseline
and subsequently
would be needed.
Prednisone would be
used for an acute
exacerbation like
the optic neuritis.
Sildenafil is the
phosphodiesterase 5
inhibitor. So it'll
increase cyclic GMP and that
allows for smooth
muscle relaxation. And
that would improve blood
flow to that area. So
it would help, say,
this patient who might
be complaining of having
EDs since they were
diagnosed or have
this worsening in MS.
But we know nothing
about that in this case.
And then teriflunamide.
If anything, we would
be concerned about
pregnancy. We would
be concerned maybe
about having
immunosuppression.
immunosuppression, but the
one that's specific for
cardiac would be the
interculating agent,
and that would be
here, mitoxantrone.
Aside from the fact
you have cardio
effects, you can
get some hair loss,
nausea, and
vomiting, which can
be managed with
an anti-emetic,
and then
immunosuppression.
So a 56-year-old female
managed for MS with
interferon beta-1a
experienced a worsening
of her symptoms,
and this included
spasms of the extremities,
which require her
now to use a wheelchair.
She can't walk.
The physician decided
to start therapy
with baclofen to help
with these muscular
effects. Which of
the following will be
the mechanism of this
drug? So here we're
discussing now the
situation where the
patient is having this
******* condition.
And the idea here is we
want to give something
that's going to
reduce muscle tone.
Relax muscle.
Muscle relaxant.
So we know that
there was two.
There was baclofen
and tizanidine.
Tizanidine is the
one that targets as
an agonist's alpha-2
receptors and that's
going to decrease
neurotransmitters
presynaptically in
the spinal cord that
will prevent the
release of the
exocitatory transmitter
known as glutamate.
Tizanidine is close
to clonidine, which is
a drug that we can
use to lower blood
pressure and heart rate
because presynaptically
it'll lower the
sympathetic overdrive.
Blockade of the M3
receptors. Again,
that would be used
for patients that have
incontinence. So
again, oxybutynin,
dyrifenicin.
Okay. We're not
dealing with this
in this question.
We're dealing
with the spasms.
Cleavage of the snare
proteins. That's
going to be again,
Botox. Okay. By cleaving
that, those proteins,
you're not going
to get the release
of acetylcholine
because SNAP25, when
it's cleaved, you're
not going to get
fusion of the vesicle.
And then you're not
going to get the
acetylcholine jumping
to the next area
where it's needed for
muscle contraction.
A GABA-B agonist,
that is baclofen.
This is going to
suppress things because
it has a G-inhibitory
action, okay?
So you're going
to decrease adenyl
cyclase, decrease
cyclic AMP, and that's
going to decrease
neurotransmitters,
especially something
like glutamate, okay?
And then inhibition
of phosphodiesterase
5 is going to
increase cyclic GMP,
and that's going to cause
smooth muscle
relaxation, okay?
And by the
way, if we were
thinking about
G-receptors,
m3 carries a gq along
with the alpha 1
receptor and i will
repeat this through
this semester and even
next year g stimulatory
is going to be
receptors like the
beta receptor the
other thing with g
inhibitory coming up
is the opioid receptors
so you'll see this
again And when we talk
about drugs like
morphine and fentanyl.
Since these drugs
are decreasing
neurotransmitters, especially
glutamate, and this
action here, especially
G-inhibitory, we're
going to expect
sedation, some CNS
depression. So what
does that mean? Well, if
patients are also
using alcohol, this can
be a problem. okay
they're going to get
into a more pronounced
sedation same thing
if they were using
say morphine for pain
they would be more
prone to have sedation
and sometimes and
this will be brought
up when we do opioids
a greater risk of
respiratory depression
okay so we'll try to
continue tying in these
concepts as we move
through pharmacology,
but thank you for
your attention, and I
hope that this question
review did help review
some of the main
concepts of the
lecture. I know it takes
a little bit longer,
but most students have
found these reviews
to be very helpful.
Thank you, everyone.
Have a great day.
Please contact me
if needed. Be well.